um there's something like that cliche is
actually so true really is man like I'm
not in love with you but I still love
you yeah and and it's just like we need
more words like like the Inuit have like
a dozen words for snow right to describe
different types of snow but we have this
one word and it's like love and yeah
like it's such a broad yeah it has a lot
of meanings well we are a lot of
different inferences I guess we took
Ella our five year old daughter to two
ramen the other night when we first like
Tatsu yeah Tatsu ramen in West Hollywood
and she's like I love you and I love
ramen because she's super excited it's
like her favorite restaurant to go to
and I'm trying to explain to her like
it's okay to love ramen noodles like to
enjoy that but it's a different kind of
love from loving your parents or loving
other people it's a completely different
thing so hopefully we'll dive into that
today we're gonna talk about breaking up
with people so that that whole saying I
I love you but I'm not in love with you
like what does that mean to you it means
to me that I that I care about you I can
love you as a person but but I don't
want to I don't see a a partnership I
don't feel the way about you
romantically that that I otherwise would
Nate what do you think about that no I
think it's really a big thing I go we're
gonna get into the into the the murky
stuff of breaking up here in a bit but I
feel like it is possible to still love
someone deeply and compassionately but
for it to take a different kind of form
than a romantic love yeah and I think
that's what I'm saying I don't feel like
we need and I know they're like
different terms the people gonna start
tweeting me it's a cop a love or
whatever and what did you say there's a
term agape love like a brotherly love oh
yeah and and so like they're different
they're different well the terms but
they're not commonly accepted agape even
that I mean that is a that's a different
language
yeah that's not English it's I mean it's
a word we stole I don't know if it's
Greek I think it's great yeah so it's
like yeah we
even so we because we have so few words
for love and English English language we
have to steal words from other languages
to describe the love that were that
we're dealing with when I think about
being in love with some are I'm sorry
loving someone but not being in love
with someone
uh-huh it's almost like I think of my
past relationships where I've just have
gotten into a routine of loving someone
and I don't know if either of you guys
has ever been in a relationship like
that where you start dating someone
things are really awesome the
chemistry's great yeah chemistry's great
and then six or eight months into it
you're like yeah I still really like
this person but you're not as excited
about it and then you know maybe yeah I
know I certainly have done this where
like after a year it's like wait a
minute like I'm probably not gonna marry
this person mm-hmm but I'm really used
to having them in my life
and I really do love them as a person
but I'm not probably going to take this
you know that that next step or whatever
it may be I guess my point is is a lot
of the times we will stay in a
relationship yes because of the
familiarity with it and it's not even
the next step thing is interested me
because there doesn't necessarily have
to be a next step like I think about my
current relationship with with back
sandela like there there are next steps
in terms of evolving as a couple but
there but it's wanting to continue to
journey down that same path together
with it yeah and sometimes we keep going
down the same path even though you're
like oh I'm going down the wrong path
and I might be dragging this other
person down the wrong path as well yeah
I'm and and we're like both going down
the wrong path because we've refused to
acknowledge the fact that hey I can
still love you from a distance and
travel in a in a different path this is
the way that I look at it right now is a
how can I thank you for all the time
that we spent together and all the ways
that you have enriched my life um and
then not hold on to it anymore and the
love can still be present right you can
so you can still love someone and be
like thank you for everything that was
an amazing run I learned a lot from you
I'm feeling like I need to go this way I
get the sense that you need to go this
way let's have a conversation about that
and then figure out how to support each
other on these journeys because if
you've built this love over time there
should be a lot of communication and
there should be a lot of support still
and then we often feel compelled to sort
of tear it down if it mmm I know in the
past I've been in relationships or where
if it hasn't worked out then all of a
sudden there's almost like this cultural
imperative to and it's so silly to me
now but there's a cultural imperative to
to shun the other person tear them down
to make them feel bad in some way
because it didn't work out or maybe I
should feel bad that it didn't work out
as opposed to the other way to look at
it is you can also graduate from a
relationship it's what Dan Savage calls
the campsite rule right you want to
leave things better than you found them
at a campsite vaccinologist went camping
this past week and I'll have no part of
that no nowhere to go no I
I'll avoid that but but I understand
'mentally I appreciate that rule where
it's like if you're going to be in a
relationship with someone whether that's
a business relationship a friendship an
acquaintanceship networking whatever it
is why not leave that that relationship
better than how you found it I've I feel
like the basis for all of this is
self-love and then communication about
what you're feeling and thinking with
the other person in an honest direct way
like the only way that I feel like you
have a good relationship and the only
way that you have a good ending to a
relationship a romantic relationship
whatever is to be completely on board
and communicative with that person and a
direct and honest and open compassionate
way yeah and I think a lot of it has to
do with what you were just talking about
your being thankful for being grateful
for the time you had together and being
able to find a way to express that
because even if it relationships ending
and even if it's not your fault that
it's ending you can be grateful for that
time that you add together and you can
still express that in a way that that
isn't mopey or overly emotional or or
accusatory because there's there's
there's also a passive-aggressive away a
passive-aggressive way to express your
gratitude
yes and we want to avoid that
you